und ich spiele zum ersten mal seit einer
ewigkeit wieder bett wars ich habe diese
karte hier noch nie gespielt wobei so
lange ist es ja gar nicht ja ich habe
mit jet auf seinem kanal ein battle
gemacht letztes aber ich werde jetzt
allein bett wars spielen und habe diese
karte noch nie gezockt und sowieso habe
ich alleine wird schon seit 3000 jahren
nicht mehr gespielt sagt sie ist es
jetzt gerade 12 uhr morgens zu mir
bleibt nicht wirklich etwas anderes
übrig weil wir natürlich videos bringen
und ich bin jetzt aber weg um 13 uhr
sonst was fährt mein zug heisst in einer
stunde deshalb mache ich jetzt einfach
einen post video und spiele ganz alleine
und hoffe mal dass ich jetzt nicht
vollkommen fälle bzw
ich glaube so etwas verlernt man ja
nicht aber wir es der batch vorbei ich
mein bett ein
man könnte natürlich sein bett einbauen
aber ich würde ich das machen werde
erstmal gutes schwert kaufen das ist
wichtigstes okay ich tue was ich bin
gerade voll auf den videos lassen sich
auch manch casey meist kennen das ja so
ein blogger das projekt locker youtuber
aus new york und er hat gerade sondern
hat ein video anschauen das was der bohr
institut jetzt gerade irgendwie voll da
drin automatisch ich bin cool markt was
auch sonst
ich hab es nicht in dem festgelegt aber
ihr braucht euch glauben bei den
kohlmarkt zählt dass ich das bin
es gibt noch genug an die macht
nur wenn halt ich auf dem server wenn
noch niemand den namen hat dann krieg
ich dann immer automatisch das ist
verboten
ja also ich habe mich irgendwie an post
sondern das plug-in hat einfach diese
möglichkeit und ich feiere das natürlich
gleich mal zum friseur dann sehe ich
wieder nach einem menschen aus die
übrigen meinen gremien merchandise von
einem hohen ball
peter ja freunde das war eine echt
extrem dumm dass sie das match aber hier
irgendwie so an die tastatur gefasst und
automatisch strg crew auch noch gedrückt
ich verwende nein taste falsch zurück
sondern gleich zwei so was macht der
kolleg hier
ich wollte gerade herunter wachsen
ich glaube das lasse ich lieber gehe ich
jetzt zu ihm sonst komplett zu mir
halten also viele andere möglichkeiten
habe ich ja gar nicht gleich kriege ich
nenne da
wie dumm war ich den gerade tut mir leid
dass ich so dumm bin und es mir ja oder
ja
hey was mache ich denn für sachen ich
sollte mich schämen dafür lauf einfach
runter und ich sag mal so etwas kann man
nicht verlernt
ich spiele zu viel geld denn freunde
aber ich wollte mich schon viele hektar
und bringen das wäre mich dann doch
etwas strange gewesen ist das schon
wieder gemacht hätte ich probiere jetzt
mal zu waschen
das wird keine ahnung wissen wir wo das
bett ist auf dieser karte nehme an hier
oben als ob also ich möchte schon sagen
kann ist einfach so easy ausschalten der
typ ist geleistet
sonst hätte ich das geschafft und das
ist ja wirklich unglücklich
das ist so etwas tue irgendwie bin ich
auch ein bisschen verballert noch zum
ferien früher morgen vorher morgen 11
uhr
ich möchte nicht wirklich sogar schon 12
und da darf man schon mal vorbei als
sein findet also die was anderes sagen
hey hey das mit gefährlich so der typ
nicht oder wie kann ich den aber in der
mitte weg vorbei so trifft nämlich safe
nicht weil ich habe keine verbindung zu
ermitteln wenn ich das so drehe wäre das
schon relativ nervös wert für nicht so
irgendwas habe ich ja also ich habe
nichts bisher muss meine
er macht so viel mehr schaden als ich
und jeder keine lust ihr land kein
wunder ich werde mich erst mal damit ein
bisschen krippen und dann schaue ich mal
ob ich vielleicht die mit doch wieder
einnehmen kann oder man fährt man ein
bisschen einbauen
ach nee das ist ja so ne karte da kann
man die betten richtig eklig einbauen
hier wenn man einfach erstmal so klar
aber klar ich werde mich auch wenn
irgendjemand hingehe werde ich auch dass
hier werde ich auch hier hingehen weil
das ist wahrscheinlich nicht jeder
kisten hin achtet man ja auch einfach
durch bauen freunde es ist nicht mehr so
leicht nicht mehr früher war es leichter
müsste wissen
aber ich freudig acker hier das dürfte
relativ sicher sein aber ich glaube ich
bin nicht der einzige der auf die idee
kommt dass zu machen ich mich ziemlich
irgendwie special fühlen wenn
wahrscheinlich alle ihre betten
einigermaßen selben habe ich aber auf
jeden fall mit justin ein spannendes
wetters so wolf ein spannendes bedburger
gemacht das könnt ihr euch liebend gerne
anschauen
danach ist das ist ein paar getan habe
aber wollen wir mal schauen ob wir uns
die leute holen können
mal sehen das leben noch viele ich
glaube ich bin der der bisher von allen
am wenigsten geschafft hat hierbei geht
dann bin ich immerhin gut da kann man
nicht viel sagen oder
also dann seid ihr hater wenn ihr sagt
ist dann schlecht und ich weise im feld
ich so etwas sage kriegen irgendwelche
kommentare so wie heißt es doch nicht
jeder automatisch hält er nur weil er
sagte schlecht und hat manche leute
einfach keine ironie verstehen aber wir
sind eigentlich voll gut jetzt wieder
gut auf krimis von drüben noch mal das
selber holen vielleicht täuschen so oder
so kommen und einen guten boden
beziehungsweise gutes schwert aber erst
mit die beste rüstung aber ich glaube
dann können wir schon wieder mitspielen
also ist eben waren wir so viele auf
seiner aber einmal in die mitte und
schon alles am start was man braucht
dann hofft man dass die runde nicht zu
lang wird jetzt weil wir die karte
spielen ich spiele ja zum ersten mal
gelang es normalerweise dauert aber es
könnte klar gehen sollte es wegwerfen
eigentlich nicht aber ich muss trotzdem
so viel zu jung oder alt das auch noch
richtig knapp
ein bisschen say wird mir eine kleine
days aufbauen
auch ich habe einen bogen aber ich
schliesse gegen die wand damit deshalb
fast vielleicht doch ein vorteil
nach dem lauf ich jetzt verdammt und von
endlich geschafft jetzt nicht gedacht
irgendwie was richtig dumm sein zu
dürfen
so
könnte noch spannend werden nach den
einmal
verdammt alte er dann noch den
abhebungen klare führung
und zwei hits freunde
ich weiß nicht ob ich mir den holen kann
dem tt rs jetzt die mittel
ach komm ist ein bisschen gold holen was
war das für ein team da wird er hier
vorne rast acht der wohl der
wahrscheinlich probiert eine seinen base
zu schnetzeln und deshalb hat der andere
kollege den hat sich nach hause
portieren müssen und hätte
wahrscheinlich gar nicht die mir
auftrieb
aber ich könnte jetzt zu meinem vorteil
nutzen und selbst ein bisschen kam so
twittern und team rot sehen wird direkte
nachbarn die sobald ich es nicht an oder
ist das nur kling kling hier vor nächste
wollte schon aufgeben erscheint bisher
nicht
er steht einfach in seiner welt und der
andere kollege von tim roth ist ihnen
irgendwie in ruhe noch mal was völlig
zudem ist schon wieder so unternehmen
fliegen um bessere waffe
ja krass über ihn
jetzt muss ich aber gut geben ok sehr
schön treff ausgelöst aber ich habe dem
bett geholt
muster für gut
sehr schön
ach komm wir auch mit einem traps ich
benutze nie aber wir sind eigentlich
voll effektiv wenn man überlegt schießt
einmal dahin
oder anderes wird lancom könnte so dann
können wir das vielleicht finden sich ja
vielleicht initiative ist auch gute
sachen aber man weiß es nicht
auch gott jetzt hängt das an
jetzt fängt das an arbeitet ich hatte ja
schon fast gedacht
ich hatte nachfolge gesagt wenn ich dann
später irgendwann angreifen dann sollte
ich das so machen
das hat ihn und jetzt kann uns
vielleicht noch den letzten gegner
ich bin team rot also dem grünholen ja
mit stolz auf diese kenntnis und dann
schaffen wir es ja eigentlich sogar ich
hätte echt gedacht dass sie es voll
verlernt habe und habe ich aber
hier setzt die reihe kriegen wenn ich so
ein bisschen schießen wenn er über sich
natürlich nichts mehr machen sehr knapp
immerhin schon wieder 25 gold die karten
fällt mir ganz gut
natürlich im prinzip sehr ähnlich es
macht schon wieder freunde was mache ich
hier
wieso tue ich das ich glaube die
facebook rate mit anschließender mit
anschließendem erliegen an den
verletzungen ist glaube ich sehr hoch
zum klick tiere
ich mache das nicht mit absicht wer so
bescheuert jetzt muss man echt was
überlegen dass der für mich deshalb
gewinnen wir was natürlich eine menge
von dem zeug um selber darum zum fig
falle ich die ganze zeit runter bis
jetzt dumm also sonst passiert mir das
auch nicht so wirst du was zu
ich gehe sehr wichtig vor mir 25 gold
einfach nicht mehr runter gefallen ist
es richtig vorher wie alle mich zu tode
erheben werden ich wünsche mir erzählt
gelegt wird erstmal zuschauen dass ich
vor dem in die mitte komme ziehe
schönheiten runter das habe ich wieder
ein bisschen gold ich habe ja noch ganz
gut geschäftsleute ich hoffe mal nicht
zu sauer auf mich
ich wäre es glaube ich aber auch selbst
wenn ich das video geschaut hätte weil
jemand anders ist es ziemlich dürfte
ziemlich bedient sein
und hat er nicht zu sehr eingebaut hier
ist echt ein guter trick dafür aber ich
habe keinen speziellen kopf was ich
jetzt vielleicht mal tun sollte das
stellt sie hatte irgendwie eine
schlechte connection und da ist er
und das war habe ich erst mal geschafft
okay leute tut mir leid dafür dass diese
dumm war die ganze zeit
ich habe zu viele termine bis dahin
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder
das war kein rein tschüss